welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i'm the
host of the show
but today i am going to be joined by a
special temporary guest co-host his name
is greg knuckles greg thanks for joining
me thanks for having me on
no problem
we have a bunch of stuff to get to in
this episode we're going to do uh
quite a few listener questions i'm also
going to talk a little bit about protein
digestion speed
kind of clarify things i alluded to
in our most recent episode but before we
get to all that um if you are interested
in supporting the show there are many
ways to do it of course you could
like rate and subscribe wherever you
happen to get podcasts like this one you
could use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com
our code is sbs pod and that gets you a
5 percent discount off of your entire
order uh other ways you could support
the show would be by subscribing to the
mass research review which we both write
every month along with uh dr eric helms
and dr mike zordos
and you could also subscribe to macro
factor which is the diet app that we
designed with a talented team
of developers and if you're not sure if
it's going to be the right app for you
we do offer a free trial so you can try
it out see if you like it and stick
around if you do
okay moving on to the content for this
week's episode um
last week we were talking a little bit
about protein it's uh
definitely a fan favorite topic um
one of the nutrition variables that
people most enjoy talking about and
manipulating in their diet and and for
good reason protein obviously
is very important to what we're trying
to do whether you're trying to
lose some body fat
you know build muscle
increase your strength increase your
performance recover better from training
protein is one of those dietary
variables that that you certainly want
to be mindful of so i was talking a
little bit about uh protein intake right
before bed um and it's been it's become
really common in the last decade or so
to say hey you really have to get some
protein in right before bed so that
you're building muscle overnight as you
sleep
and in last week's episode i talked
about the research
looking at pre-bed protein
supplementation and in reality
based on the evidence we have currently
it looks like before bed is an excellent
time to get some protein in but it
doesn't seem to be
particularly special it doesn't look
like you are really leaving gains on the
table if you finish all your protein
earlier in the day but you're still
spreading it out throughout the day at
least an eight hour feeding window at
least three large doses of protein
throughout the day if you're getting
enough total protein and spreading it
out kind of and getting at least a few
servings per day it doesn't look like
it's absolutely imperative to have
protein right before bed
but in the context of having that
conversation
i i mentioned that casein before bed
isn't quite as special as people
sometimes lead you to believe
well-intentioned people you know it's
kind of a
a really common recommendation is before
bed gets some casein because casein
digests really slowly it's absorbed very
slowly so therefore it's going to have a
more favorable
response in terms of blood amino acid
levels and therefore protein synthesis
and therefore muscle building that's
kind of the common recommendation but uh
i mentioned that
that whole line of logic just didn't
make a lot of sense to me um but i also
mentioned that casein itself isn't
really that slow
and when you look at other proteins in
terms of its digestion and absorption
speed so i wanted to take a moment in
this week's episode to talk a little bit
more about protein digestion speed and
what i'm talking about here is digestion
and absorption which are two different
processes but i'm just going to refer to
them i'm going to lump them together and
talk about digestion speed but i wanted
to acknowledge that on the front and i'm
talking about the rate at which
a dietary protein source is digested and
absorbed and then you know ultimately
we're talking about the rate at which
blood amino acid levels are increasing
so
um there's a lot of there are a lot of
misconceptions about uh
what exactly
that information tells us related to
muscle building i think it's really
intuitive
to assume that
we should or can
really micromanage those blood amino
acid responses in a way that can be more
favorable you know i think it's
a particular variable that people like
to think about manipulating very
carefully and saying okay i'm going to
peak blood amino acid levels at this
time that time that time and that time
and therefore i've optimized my protein
for the day so
first before we get into what can and
cannot be achieved i think it's
important to talk about just like the
the general conceptual model of what
we're doing when we eat protein so
we ingest protein that ideally is going
to contain some amount of leucine and
some amount of essential amino acids
as a result of that we're going to have
increased leucine levels in our blood um
and leucine obviously triggers muscle
protein synthesis it's a really key
amino acid that initiates that response
in muscle so leucine very very important
at the same time we're also going to
have an increase in the blood levels of
essential amino acids and they're
important because they enable the
synthesis of new muscle proteins so what
we need is uh we eat some protein we
need blood levels of leucine and
essential amino acids to go up so that
the muscle gets the signal to start
building and synthesizing new proteins
and we need the essential amino acids to
be there in sufficient quantities so
that we can actually build those
proteins
now this response here where we consume
protein and we start synthesizing new
proteins in the muscle
this
this protein synthesis response is
maximized for a brief time and then it
goes back down and it needs to be
re-stimulated and over time
positive balance between muscle protein
synthesis and muscle protein breakdown
is ultimately going to lead to
hypertrophy so that is the basic idea of
how protein ingestion relates to blood
amino acid levels which relates to
building proteins in our muscle and
ultimately building muscle over time so
when you lay out the process like that
it seems really intuitive to assume that
that we need to really micromanage these
variables have these very targeted
spikes in leucine levels and essential
amino acid levels
and that if you compare
blood responses of amino acids you
should therefore be comparing
how well these things are are supporting
uh hypertrophy in a sense
uh there was one study that was really
fascinating um
you know one of the most common uh
conversations or debates in the protein
world is
animal based proteins versus plant-based
proteins and there was a study by
brennan and colleagues
where they compared four different
protein sources so one of them was
whey protein
kind of the the gold standard when it
comes to promoting muscle protein
synthesis a very very uh high performing
protein in that context and they were
comparing three different uh kind of
test products these were formulations
that were different blends of pea
protein and pumpkin protein and
sunflower and coconut protein uh just
kind of multi-plant blend and they had
three different versions that they were
testing what's really interesting about
this study is that all four treatments
had the same leucine content so 2.6
grams per serving uh they had the same
protein digestibility corrected amino
acid score uh which was 1.0 because also
you know we're comparing to whey protein
and they had the same
content of total essential amino acids
those are the those raw materials to
actually synthesize new muscle proteins
uh and so in order to make all that
stuff work the plant-based protein
blends ultimately had a higher absolute
dose so in order to match them with whey
it was about 33 or 34 grams of these
plant-based proteins
being compared to 24 grams of whey
now what they found was that the whey
protein
compared to the other three plant
protein blends
resulted in greater peak and area under
curve values for
essential amino acids in blood and also
leucine levels in blood
so basically the whey protein was
causing these really large fairly rapid
spikes in leucine and essential amino
acids when compared to these plant
proteins and so a very intuitive
conclusion would be
you know that's probably not great you
know that's not a great sign for these
plant proteins perhaps they're not as
good for initiating muscle protein
synthesis and by extension perhaps
they're not as good for building you
know new muscle over time
but it's really important to recognize
that um blood amino acid responses are
not a perfect proxy for muscle protein
synthesis
and
be going beyond that muscle protein
synthesis is not a perfect proxy for
actually building muscle over time for
lean mass gains or
you know increased muscle
cross-sectional area over time and so
one of the things that's really
important to keep in mind
uh is that it doesn't take a very high
peak if you're trying to max out this
muscle protein synthesis response i mean
you you do need to
you know get more leucine and more
essential amino acids in the blood to to
kind of initiate and maximize this
response but we can't always say that a
a more rapid response or a greater peak
is necessarily better for muscle protein
synthesis
and a secondary point that's important
to consider is that the time course of
muscle protein synthesis does not
perfectly mirror the time course of
blood amino acid responses so um there's
a really great article online by yorn
trommelin dr yorn trommelin um
i forget what is it
nutritiontactics.com is that his website
so he's got a great uh it's this huge
article about muscle protein synthesis
i'll link it in the show notes i'm
blanking on the exact title of the
article um but in it he talks about the
muscle full effect uh and generally
speaking i think it's just called
something like a complete guide to
muscle protein synthesis yeah that
sounds yeah that sounds right
but i'll link it in the show notes but
he talks about the muscle full effect
and uh basically after we consume
protein there's a lag period about 45 to
90 minutes
even if there's a really rapid spike in
blood amino acid levels there's this
little lag time and then muscle protein
synthesis goes up and it peaks somewhere
between 90 to 120 minutes
and then muscle protein synthesis rates
return to baseline
after that time point even if
amino acid levels are still elevated in
the blood so what you see is temporally
there there's not this kind of perfect
mirroring where we can manipulate amino
acid
responses and thereby manipulate muscle
protein synthesis responses these two
things are disconnected
so
what we
are trying to do with a protein serving
is not micromanage the digestion and
absorption rate so we can micromanage
those uh you know amino acid responses
in blood we're just trying to make sure
that for this protein feeding
opportunity we have enough leucine
enough essential amino acids
with reasonably good digestibility
so that we will achieve basically a
maximal or near maximal peak you know so
we can initiate this process
now another thing that that's really
interesting sometimes you'll see
comparisons of fast versus slow protein
and a question is you know we know that
they're going to have different uh
responses in terms of you know the the
time course for leucine going up and
down in the blood or essential amino
acids going up and down in the blood but
another interesting set of questions is
forget those differences just comparing
protein synthesis rates are fast
proteins better than slow proteins in
terms of their digestion rate
or looking at hypertrophy over time are
fast proteins better or worse than slow
proteins
what's really interesting though is
you have to be really careful as you go
through this research there's a really
nice uh review article by watard and
colleagues where they were looking at
comparing faster proteins versus slower
proteins really wave protein versus
others
and whey protein in a certain
collection of studies looked to be much
better for stimulating muscle protein
synthesis
but a key issue there was
how long the actual measurement period
was so it's easy to look into the
research and find areas where people say
oh yeah whey protein outperforms slower
proteins cut and dry very simple very
straightforward but it's usually in
studies where they only measure protein
synthesis rates for a period of four
hours or fewer so a very short time
frame when you start looking at studies
that are like five hours six hours or
more those differences between fast and
slow proteins start to look uh
much smaller they start to look very
similar in terms of their capability to
uh to promote muscle protein synthesis
over extended time frames yeah so there
are a few studies um
not as many as you think honestly but
there are a few studies looking at fast
versus slow proteins
um uh
looking at you know actual longitudinal
outcomes so like i said amino acid
responses don't tell us everything about
muscle protein synthesis rates and
muscle protein synthesis rates don't
tell us everything about building muscle
over time longitudinally
so there's a study by willborn and
colleagues which i'll link in the i'll
link these studies in the show notes but
they looked at pre and post exercise
supplementation with whey or casein
looking at body composition changes over
time in female collegiate athletes and
the short version of the results is
there was really no difference no no
substantial difference between whey or
casein
looking at longitudinal changes in body
composition over time
there's another study by fabre and
colleagues where they were looking at
basically trying to find an optimal
ratio between fast and slow proteins so
what they would do is take
i think they were looking at different
combinations of whey protein and either
milk protein or casein protein but they
were basically kind of taking away as
the example of a fast protein and
cutting it with different amounts of
slower proteins to manipulate the
digestion rate
and what they found was
whichever way you went with you know
fast medium slow
in the long run it just didn't really
seem to matter that much
but but this is all talking about kind
of the milk based spectrum of proteins
like whey milk protein casein
but i mentioned in the last episode that
casein isn't actually that slow in the
grand scheme of thing when you look at
other
other protein sources so
i've got a table here from a paper by
oh man i'm blanking on the name but i'll
link this paper in the show notes as
well
billsboro is the first is the first
author for sure
but they have a nice little table here
that shows the
approximate
absorption rate for different protein
sources and they've got the individual
references and it's really surprisingly
hard to track this information down you
have to kind of go study by study
looking at individual proteins this is
the one of the only reviews i'm aware of
that really lays it out
really clearly with several different
protein sources but so for example uh
whey isolate in this table the
absorption rate is eight to ten grams
per hour um casein isolate is 6.1 grams
per hour
so uh those are actually like pretty
pretty fast compared to the rest of the
fields so yeah they're they're the two
fastest uh like complete proteins like
not just
like various free amino acid profiles on
this table right and i try not to treat
this table as like uh set in stone
because any time you're looking at
absorption rates there are so many
contextual factors to keep in mind
cooking process
or cooking um
how the protein was cooked uh how the
specific product was processed like
how it was uh the context in which it
was delivered in the study there's a lot
that can go into
uh modulating the absorption rate but
and it's not a fully comprehensive table
it's it's eight different protein
sources and then two different blends of
free amino acids yeah exactly um but but
just to kind of contextualize it like
this table lists uh soy protein isolate
is 3.9 grams per hour it lists uh
raw egg protein as 1.3 grams per hour as
i alluded to cooking can facilitate that
digestion pretty considerably
but even cooked egg protein is listed as
2.8 grams per hour and again we're
talking about casein being listed at 6.1
so we view casein as a
it's
very
uh
natural to assume that it's this
extremely slowly absorbed protein just
because of the way it's discussed in the
industry but what they're really doing
is looking at okay we've got of the milk
proteins we've got the whey fraction and
casein uh which one is slower of the two
that's why they're kind of going with
casein so much is uh they're kind of
restricting their themselves to
uh the milk based protein spectrum but
casein is certainly not an outlier in
terms of a super slow digestion rate um
so
that kind of begs the question you know
maybe these studies that i mentioned
previously on fast and slow proteins
maybe there were no differences because
we're talking about a very fast protein
and a still kind of fast-ish protein
right
actually eric before we move on
looking at this table
i have a question that's slightly out of
left field okay so this table is listing
absorption rates in grams per hour
and it goes from 1.3 for raw egg protein
to 8 to 10 for whey isolate
uh but you know
a fair a fair number of the protein seem
to be kind of
clustered in the three to four and a
half grams per hour range
so i i'm having a hard time
squaring that
with just like general protein
recommendations for
just you know like trying to get 1.6
grams per kilo or whatever uh because
like 3.5
grams per hour absorption rate would
imply
that you were only able to absorb about
84 grams of protein per day
uh and you know
several of these seem to be kind of
clustered around there um
like how how is that circle squared
uh like does that imply that maybe the
absorption rate data is slightly
imprecise like underestimating what the
absorption rates could be
because like my my understanding
is that there's
really no
upper level of how much protein you can
absorb and use
like within a meal or
even within like a day
within reason so how
how does that all kind of work out
yeah i'd have to look into the
quantification method for these
absorption rates um
that's that's kind of why i couched the
uh or i i had the caveat for this table
of like you know let's let's not look
into the numbers as set in stone super
literal and then try to build out uh
kind of mechanistic explanations from
there i view this table as more of
directionality you know so so kind of
setting these um
not taking the number as a literal
value to build daily protein
recommendations from but to look at
comparing this protein versus that
protein with protein which is faster
which is slower i think we can
definitely use it for that type of
comparison purpose
so ultimately what i'm trying to do here
is kind of set a spectrum that that
shows that slow proteins are not
anchored by casein there are many
dietary proteins that are digested and
absorbed more slowly
in terms of you know the nitty-gritty of
how we use those absorption speed
numbers and extrapolate those to daily
protein recommendations that would take
considerably more homework
but ultimately we would be
trying to um
we would be trying to
work our way to a conclusion that we
already know
we're just trying to basically make the
numbers feel better because
as you alluded to uh we know that humans
can absorb uh considerable amounts of
protein throughout the day uh numbers
that certainly exceed what would look
like the upper end of what we see in
these particular numbers so we would be
trying to uh like you said kind of make
the square peg fit into into the round
hole there or vice versa but
but ultimately
we know that protein absorption
generally takes care of itself in a
healthy individual with no
gastrointestinal issues so um yeah i'd
have to look into the exact
quantification details for that fair
enough but anyway uh you know casein not
an unusually slow protein but even when
we look at comparisons between uh you
know slower proteins
and their less slow counterparts so for
example there have been studies looking
at whole egg which is a pretty slow
absorbing protein and comparing whole
eggs to iso nitrogenous amounts of egg
whites uh i mean i i don't know of any
bodybuilder who has
really been concerned that eggs are not
a quality protein source i mean they've
been a staple in the bodybuilding diet
for as long as
i mean
it it's as old as time the method of
using eggs for uh for bodybuilding
purposes so
um anecdotally i think the the position
of eggs and the protein hierarchy is
well established but uh you might
consider you know based on you know
trying to
get these maximized really rapid peaks
and leucine and essential amino acids
you might consider maybe i should be
using egg whites instead of whole eggs
for you know for a more rapid digestion
rate absorption rate etc uh but
generally speaking you know there's a
study by vanvlier and colleagues there's
a study by bugarian colleagues whole
eggs versus egg whites in iso
nitrogenous conditions there really just
doesn't seem to be much of a difference
there so if you try to slow down a fast
protein like changing way into a mixture
of whey and casein doesn't seem to
really do much if you try to speed up a
very slow protein by going from a whole
egg to an egg white again it doesn't
really seem to do much and when we look
at the totality of the evidence here
it just doesn't look like it makes a lot
of sense to to lose sleep over how
quickly or slowly your proteins are
digesting whether we're talking about a
daytime feeding or a nighttime feeding
the really important thing here with any
protein feeding is like i mentioned
earlier we need to make sure that
there's enough leucine that we're going
to get a nice robust spike in leucine
whether it happens very quickly or it
takes some time to accumulate in the
blood that's not that doesn't seem to be
a major concern we just need to make
sure that in the hours that follow that
feeding
are we going to get a robust leucine
response and essential amino acid
response as long as those are
accumulating in the blood and reaching
relatively high levels
then we should be initiating muscle
protein synthesis and we should have the
raw materials to build new muscle
proteins
so we definitely want to
get out of that mindset of trying to
really micromanage these amino acid
responses and these absorption times
it's probably
a situation where as you often say the
juice isn't really worth the squeeze and
all the stress that goes into it so we
need enough leucine we need enough
essential amino acids we need good
enough digestibility and absorption
rates for this protein for a lot
to allow them to accumulate in the blood
but we don't need it to be optimized we
just need it to be good enough it just
we just need enough accumulation of
those things to make it work so a faster
peak a higher peak more leucine more
essential amino acids they will not
always translate to better outcomes in
the endpoints that we really care about
which is building muscle mass
or you know what insert whatever your
goal happens to be but when it comes to
hypertrophy good enough is good enough
when it comes to digestion rate uh
absorption rate digestibility
and the overall content of leucine an
essential amino acid so uh like i said
those are kind of the key things we're
looking for and it's really not
difficult to find a protein source that
enables
a maximal or nearly maximal response
that we're looking for here
you know so
i understand why people like to look
into some of the mechanistic research on
you know plasma leucine responses or
plasma essential amino acid responses
and try to extrapolate i certainly
understand why people try to extrapolate
from some of those very short window
studies looking at muscle protein
synthesis but when you look at the
longitudinal studies looking at actually
building muscle tissue over time
frankly it just doesn't seem to matter
that much
so i i kind of briefly alluded to that
when i was talking about nighttime
protein but i wanted to take a moment to
elaborate and explain why i really don't
sweat over it and then once again as i
mentioned last week
even if we found that all of this stuff
mattered a lot
you could maybe use that information at
breakfast and then everything else goes
out the window because when you're
eating a particular protein source if
you have other things in the meal other
carbohydrate other fat other fiber
that's going to basically eliminate the
utility of pretty much all the research
i just mentioned because it drastically
alters
absorption times and the same thing goes
for any previous meal so if you had
breakfast at nine in the morning and
you're fretting over the speed of your
protein source that you're going to
consume consume for lunch at like noon
or 1 pm
it you don't really know based on the
research what the digestion absorption
rate is going to be because it's going
to be impacted by the previous meal
anyway so it doesn't make a lot of sense
to stress over
all right making sense to me
we're going to move on and the rest of
the show basically is going to be a
bunch of q and a's um so i want to let
you go first with some of your q and a's
and then i will revisit some of mine
after yeah let's go for it so um
first off for the listeners apologies in
advance uh allergy season has started in
north carolina
and uh that affects me deeply uh so i'm
on
enough antihistamines right now to uh
probably put a large buffalo to sleep uh
and i'm still very stuffy so i'm out of
it i'm probably gonna be sniffling a lot
uh this isn't going to be my best work
this is what we in the biz call managing
expectations
uh but whatever let's uh let's go for it
so anyway um
starting with some questions from
facebook
grim re
asks uh
in terms of hypertrophy is there any
significant difference between only
doing one exercise targeting the
particular muscle you're trying to train
in five different exercises as long as
volume and intensity are matched
so overall it shouldn't make that big of
a difference as far as just kind of like
overall muscle hypertrophy goes uh there
have been two or three studies looking
at this just training a muscle with only
one exercise versus a combination of
different exercises
and you don't tend to see
particularly notable differences in
terms of just
overall kind of global gross measures of
increases in muscle size but what you do
see pretty frequently um
is differences in terms of regional
hypertrophy so for example um
if you only trained your quads with one
quad exercise versus a variety of quad
exercises um
you know your your total increase in
quadriceps cross-sectional area will
probably be pretty comparable regardless
but using a variety of exercises helps
ensure that all four heads of the
quadriceps are
more evenly developed
whereas like you know maybe you might
have more say preferential vastus
lateralis development
or
vastus medialis development or something
like that if you only used one exercise
similarly
there's a study we've talked about on
the podcast before
looking at triceps growth following
just doing skull crushers versus bench
press versus a combination of skull
crushers and bench press and the skull
skull crushers and bench press were both
independently pretty good for overall
triceps growth
but the
skull crushers seem to be particularly
good for the long head of the triceps
which is biarticular
and the bench press seem to be
particularly good for the monoarticular
heads of the triceps like the the two
that don't cross the shoulder joint uh
and a combination of both uh skull
crushers and bench press
seemed to be
necessary or at least beneficial to
ensure that all of the heads of the
triceps grew pretty robustly
um so yeah i i don't think you strictly
need
a bunch of exercise variety just for
just to get big in general um but if
regional hypertrophy uh matters to you
or
if ensuring even development of all of
the heads of a particular muscle matters
quite a bit to you
then there might be benefits for more
exercise variety
all right sean noonan asks
i want to know why the sbs group only
has 4.4 000 members on facebook but
goddamn jim stepani group has almost 120
000
there's a clear answer to this uh the
universe is fundamentally fair um if
a
individual has a larger audience or if
something is more popular successful
that means that it's necessarily better
so
this is the day that we finally have to
come clean and admit that jim stepani is
a far better source of information than
we are
dr oz is a better source of information
than jim stephanie is
and you can just look through the world
if someone is doing well that means that
they are
doing you know they're being rewarded by
god for for doing good stuff in the
world
uh and that you know i i think that's a
world view with
really no complications and it comports
well with reality so can i can i admit
something yeah uh
so when i first got it like really into
lifting it was um
my wrestling coach and i would lift
together and we got really into it and
we were doing all sorts of bodybuilding
type stuff
and it was great like i i really fell in
love with fitness from these these
training sessions and
uh a lot of times what we would do is we
would just rip a page right out of uh i
think it was muscle and fitness at the
time where jim stepani was doing a ton
of the content
and so like
i'm not being ironic or like facetious
whatsoever
jim stephanie fully got me into fitness
like my only exposure to fitness was jim
stefani programs and articles
and i remember when i was like 16 and i
was like dude i want to get into the
fitness industry because i love
rigorous hard-hitting evidence-based
content uh such as jim stepani yeah
that's that's fully what got me into it
so can i admit something to you
yeah and to to everyone we are on on
microphones i actually don't know
anything about jim stapani i i i know
that he is a
favorite punching bag
of
uh evidence-based fitness folks yeah
i've not consumed any of his content my
one and only exposure to him was and i
think this is still on the internet
somewhere he may have taken it off of
youtube but i think it's still on vimeo
and you know exactly what i'm gonna say
yeah uh there is a video of him doing
plyometric smith machine bicep curls uh
talking about how like the explosive
contraction from like curling the
curling the bar and throwing it up is
going to be super good for biceps growth
uh and it's also very clear that he's
reading off of cue cards that are off
camera and so
it's one a bizarre exercise and two it's
delivered at a speaking cadence that no
other human would ever use or has ever
used and it's
like it it's it's the uncanny valley
like he comes across as non-human in
that video
um and so that was my only exposure to
him and i was i was just like ah you
know what maybe not worth my time
reading the sky stuff so yeah yeah i i
know people are
are upset at him for
various things but quite frankly i don't
know and i don't care yeah i haven't
been uh
really engaged with that cinematic
universe since i again since i was like
16 or 17
but i do recall uh thinking back
a lot of it was just like
let's really lean into the fun
interesting side of science
you know and like
no like plyometrics are interesting for
the types of adaptations they yield for
athletes and so if you're involved in a
a sport that prioritizes explosiveness
like plyometrics are very cool like they
are a fascinating evidence-based
training technique but you know jim
would be the kind of guy who's like yeah
but what if you needed this to have big
biceps yeah and that's not at all what
they're for but it was like let's take a
fun training method that is in the
scientific literature
and make it more of like a fitness
bodybuilding magazine kind of topic
and so yeah i do remember
thinking
i had to be super rigid with my meal
timing
i remember thinking i had to be uh one
of the things he was really big on was
like uh you have to have
the right uh glycemic index value for
your post-workout carbohydrate so that
you can refuel
but like the program that i was doing
that like he wrote
it's like you hit chest on thursday and
you've got like six days until you hit
it again or like four days and i'm like
yeah i think i could have oats and still
be okay
you know so it was just um it was a lot
of stressing over the little details
that need not be stressed over
uh so it was taking like hey let's look
at this science that has a very specific
application and just work that into what
we're doing so it was you know uh
it was a great way honestly to
to fall in love with exercise science
more generally and to see all of these
uh kind of niche topics brought to you
but regrettably they were brought to you
in a way that was like hey have you
tried worrying about this and it was
something i shouldn't have been worried
about yeah yeah yeah i gotcha that makes
sense
uh all right moving on uh amanda casimir
says
bones and specifically is there any
research on what type of loading
frequency volume and movement types are
optimal for building or maintaining bone
density
um
and so yeah so just to start with uh
it's hard to give
a kind of like detailed dose response
accounting of all of those different
variables and how they may relate to
um increasing or preserving bone mineral
density uh just because like there
aren't that many of the types of studies
you would need to
um look into that in a ton of detail
like there there are quite a few studies
that are just like hey we're gonna have
people do
uh like cardio versus resistance
training for six months and then let's
see how those things affect bone
or there have been quite a few studies
looking at like hey we're going to do
high intensity or low intensity
resistance training for a while let's
see how that affects bone but you know
there's like four different variables
mentioned here and there's you know
there's not that much research looking
at volume there's not that much research
looking at frequency um or anything like
that and part of the reason for that
um like the reason why
it's difficult to
really
strictly quantify this stuff and also to
run studies that would be necessary to
to
research
the effects of exercise on bone health
in depth like different dose response
relationships
is that you need to run a pretty long
study to actually measure anything so
for example if you're interested in say
hypertrophy you recruit some untrained
subjects have them train for about eight
weeks and uh not only
are they likely to grow quite a bit of
muscle in eight weeks but
that might be long enough for you to
actually be able to see large enough
differential responses that you can
measure them and quantify them and put a
p value on it and say like oh yeah these
two things are actually different
boom we just learned something
with bone since it adapts so much more
slowly
you typically need either much larger
sample sizes or much longer study
durations
for
just changes themselves to become
measurable and even larger sample sizes
or even longer studies for differences
between groups to become large enough to
become measurable like so you know
instead of adaptations that take place
over a matter of weeks to months we're
talking about adaptations that take
place over the span of months to years
which is just inherently more
challenging to study
uh but what i will say uh and this i
think surprises some folks there was a
meta-analysis on this uh that that i can
pull up uh and put in the show notes
that was looking at the impact of
training intensity like high load versus
low load training on
uh bone mineral density in older adults
and i think a lot of people anticipate
that high intensity resistance training
would be a lot better than lower
intensity resistance training
just because like if you've been exposed
to wolf's law you're kind of aware of
the fact that bone remodeling uh is
dependent on the magnitude of the stress
placed on the muscle so higher intensity
training more intense muscle
contractions that's going to give you a
larger stimulus for adaptation right
but i think
so ultimately it doesn't seem like it
matters that much and i think one of the
reasons why
and i've mentioned this on the podcast
before but i think it's been a couple
years is i think people
um
one don't
exactly realize why resistance training
is beneficial for bone health
and two
uh fail to appreciate just how [ __ ]
strong your muscles are so
uh the
the aspect of resistance training that
is most beneficial for bone health is
the compressive forces on the bone like
basically muscle is contracting uh and
it's it's spanning the length of a bone
uh maybe it's spanning two joints maybe
it's uh originating on a bone and
inserting past the end of the bone but
basically when that muscle is
contracting it's putting compressive
force uh on the bone and that is the
stimulus for bone remodeling cool stuff
and so i think a lot of people
um
you know when we're
looking at say optimizing squat
biomechanics or something like that
we're generally quantifying external
forces so basically what are the forces
that the barbell is placing on the body
that we then have to overcome
and so i think a lot of people think
about bone remodeling from a similar
paradigm almost like you look at the
external resistance and the sorts of
forces that the external resistance is
placing on the bones and the joints and
you're like okay like that is what's
causing the the compressive forces
leading to bone remodeling but most of
the compressive forces that your bones
are feeling are actually just coming
from the muscle contraction itself so
for example if you're interested in
uh like forces on the femur
like compressive forces on the femur
maybe they're greater in the squat than
the knee extension because like you know
you have the bar pressing down on your
body like there are some external
compressive forces uh resulting from
just the load of the bar itself but most
of the compressive forces on the femur
are just coming from the quads
contracting really hard so it's not like
there's an order of magnitude difference
of compressive force on the femur from
the squat versus the knee extension
um
so that's the first thing like most of
those forces are just coming from the
the force of the muscle contraction
itself and then two your muscles are
very strong um like the human body
is built in a way
where
we're designed for mobility more so than
force output
so for example uh
i think this is just easiest to see with
the bicep like your bicep inserts very
close to your elbow so
uh you know it's
like the the
length from your
like the distance from the middle of
your elbow to your hand is probably like
10 times greater than the distance from
the insertion of your bicep to the
center of the elbow joint itself so
essentially like you know if you were to
curl
50 pounds
with one hand say
your bicep is probably contracting with
around 500 pounds of force uh like that
that's just how it has to work for you
to be able to overcome that external
resistance
500 pounds of force is a ton of force
like i i don't think most people like if
you can curl 50 pounds with one hand i
don't think it's going through your head
like oh my biceps are producing four or
500 pounds of contractile force right
now but they are uh and that's
that's how basically all of your muscles
at basically all of your joints work
your muscles are
originate and insert very close to the
joints that they cross um so they have
to be contracting with an enormous
amount of force to move an external
resistance
so
you know
even if you're doing
relatively low intensity resistance
training your muscles are still
contracting with a ton of force to move
that resistance and they're contracting
with more force if it's a higher
resistance but
you're putting a lot of compressive
forces on your bones if you're doing
anything that's really even remotely
challenging within the realm of
resistance training
so
my advice is basically just do
resistance training um
and i'm sure there is an intensity
somewhere that would be too low like you
know if you're just doing single joint
exercises and you're using weights that
you can do for sets of 200 like yeah
maybe that's not enough contractile
force to lead to robust bone remodeling
but if you're doing resistance training
with any sort of load that
becomes challenging after fewer than 20
or 30 reps you're putting
an enormous amount of compressive forces
on your bones
which seems to be more than sufficient
for bone remodeling to either improve
bone mineral density or preserve it as
you age
so yeah um
i
i can't give a super like hyper specific
recommendation for optimal loading
because ultimately like one as i
mentioned originally that research
doesn't exist to really dial in a super
optimized prescription but two and more
importantly i don't think that's
necessary because if you're doing
resistance training
you're getting the job done as far as
preserving bone health goes
um let's see and then m8
asks or mh asks
everything old is new again
what's a training or nutrition strategy
from the past that you would like to see
come back or that you think will come
back or that you'd love to see come back
uh i i think we can both address this
one but uh
starting
with me
i think that something that i would love
to see come back
is just kind of the old vibe of physical
culture and who knows how true this
actually was like back in the day when
it was happening happening concurrently
but at least in terms of what has been
preserved and passed down to us about
like bodybuilding and strength sports
and the whole
physical culture deal um like maybe
pre-1950 or so
uh is that
a lot of it just seemed to be focused on
just
trying to improve and preserve general
health and physical resilience
um there there didn't seem to be quite
as much
of a focus so like if you if you talk to
a physique athlete or a strength athlete
now
you will very rarely hear them say like
yes i'm i'm doing this for my health
like getting down to
five percent body fat for a bodybuilding
show not the healthiest thing you can do
uh
trying to like squeak
every last kilo you can possibly get out
of your deadlift
maybe not the healthiest thing you can
do um
and so like it seemed like the entire
purpose of people exercising back in the
day
they kind of had a more holistic view of
it of like i want to look good i want to
be able to perform well in
quite a few different physical
capacities and that should
just make me a more robust person
improve my health yada yada yada
and somewhere along the line
uh and i i wouldn't want to uh like
posit a complete list of causes but i i
do think like drug culture uh like
steroid culture um was was a pretty
large contributor to this um like i i
and you know probably
um
probably visual culture as well like the
the drive to achieve more and more
extreme looks to to kind of draw
people's attention i i think that those
were probably too
large contributing factors to this um
but yeah like i i think that
the
entire vibe around physical culture is
less
general health focused than it was
before but yeah it used to just be like
yeah this is something i like doing
makes my life better makes me healthier
and i think that especially if you get
into
one specific discipline
uh
a lot these days i i do think that
that focus on general health and
resiliency isn't there as much anymore
um and i i would like to see that come
back i think that would be a good thing
yeah
i don't know i'm racking my brain i'm
not really sure
if i have a
a great answer for this um
whenever i think about
things changing over time uh i i kind of
view it through the
the sports nutrition prism
and so i
i think you would do pretty good on the
betting markets if you just said what's
popular now and said i think in 10 years
we're going to hate that
uh so
i would imagine that you know right now
the the pendulum has swung quite a bit
if you go back uh
you know 20 years
the prevailing wisdom was
you know high carb moderate protein
quite low fat
and that pendulum has swung pretty hard
to the point where now it's
high
protein high fat uh quite low
carbohydrate that seems to be kind of
the uh the flavor of the day in terms of
nutrition
so
uh there are many uh you know cultural
things within physical culture like you
mentioned that that could be uh improved
upon you know it seems like back in the
day people just had a lot more fun
with their training like it seemed like
there was a lot more camaraderie in gyms
and people did it
uh
because they enjoyed it and it was
almost like a club and uh there was a
lot of unity in that
uh
man nowadays
perhaps i've been too impacted by the
animal pack advertisements but man it
sometimes it seems like people train
these days to exercise their demons and
it's like yeah that was not how it was
portrayed in the 70s and 80s you know
that kind of golden era bodybuilding it
was like hey
we all have similar interests you want
to be my friend sure like you want to
spot me you want to like stand on my
back while i do donkey calf raises like
it was just yeah there are a lot of
things like that where i think the vibes
can improve it seems like it's gotten
uh hyper hyper hyper competitive and it
just has like a little tinge of
negativity compared to
compared to yesteryear
um but but more focused on the nutrition
side
i expect
that right now this this big wave of
all the focus being on protein and fat
as really really positive things we're
probably going to see over the next 10
years things settling back to
i would expect more similar to what
people were doing in the 80s in terms of
the general consensus for
hey i'm getting into lifting how should
i eat i think people are going to get
away from the current trend which is
increasingly promoting you know keto and
carnivore and things like that and and i
i should also mention that like i don't
even think there's that that that many
people who are actually doing it i just
think that seems to be the content that
that is getting shared around the most
like
the amount of carnivore diet content i
see these days
cannot possibly be reflective of the
number of people actually eating a
carnivore diet i hope not because i
don't know a single person who's even
tried it yeah but everywhere i look on
instagram it's you know people eating a
giant raw liver
uh so yeah that that would be my answer
if that counts yeah
something else that i would love to see
come back uh and i i don't think it ever
will but i i think one of the things you
touched on is that
gym culture seemed to be
[Music]
a lot more communal back in the day and
a lot less individualistic and that's
something i've seen just in my time
since i started training um
the the invention of bluetooth
headphones and mp3 players uh has been
nothing but an unmitigated disaster for
gym culture in my book um
like
and
one thing i'll note is this this is
coming from my perspective um talking to
female lifters who say that
like being able to put on big noise
canceling headphones to project to
people like hey
i'm not available to talk right now like
please don't interrupt my workout uh you
know they
very well may have a different
perspective on this uh but man
when i started training like
15 16 years ago
um you go in a gym and you know there's
music playing over the speakers but like
no one has earbuds in no one has
headphones on because you know the the
best thing for listening to music was
like a walkman or like a portable cd
player you know you don't really want to
have that in your pocket when you're
working out and so there was
i think just much more of a sense of
camaraderie because
if you're doing something between sets
you're either staring at the ground or
you're talking to people uh and most of
the time you just talk to people and so
the first half dozen gyms i trained in
like i knew everyone we were all friends
like sometimes we'd hang out outside of
the gym
you know what was going on in their
lives
it was a lot easier to ask for a spot
because people were just kind of looking
around observing what was going on
easier to make eye contact like
people weren't as absorbed in in their
own world like listening to music or
podcasts or whatever
um
and yeah i feel like
i feel like gyms now
can feel
like the the idea of like when small
town people move to a big city and it's
like there are so many people here yet i
feel so alone like i think that there's
that vibe in a lot of gyms now i think
that's one of the the factors in the
success of crossfit like because it is
and uh like fitness classes and like
ymcas like i think that those are
popular and not so much crossfit anymore
but group exercise definitely continuing
to grow in popularity um because it does
give you that sense of camaraderie that
kind of communal environment like hey
we're all kind of doing this we're in it
together you can chat with with the
other people in your classes or in your
box
uh and yeah i i personally prefer
that vibe much better i wish it would
come back but i don't see gyms banning
headphones uh
i wouldn't be in favor of them doing
that you know people can live their
lives however they want but i do in my
opinion that has been
a disaster for for the vibe of gyms um
yeah but yeah it is what it is
all right so um let's see here i've got
a question from grim re
uh the question is is postprandial
induced increase of muscle protein
synthesis a strong indicator of
hypertrophy
uh in other words is there a significant
difference uh
in hypertrophy over the long term
between eating two meals a day versus
eating every three to four hours as long
as protein and total caloric intake are
matched
i view that as two very different
questions
and i think
that so the first question is
is muscle protein synthesis after a meal
is that a strong indicator or predictor
of hypertrophy very easy the answer is
no
i'll link a paper in the show notes it's
a review paper by wetard and colleagues
i think i pronounce his name differently
every time i say it but that's okay
um but yeah so in their review paper
here it was called making sense of
muscle protein synthesis a focus on
muscle growth during resistance training
i'm not sure if i've mentioned this on
this podcast before because i feel like
i've been talking about it non-stop
elsewhere like i've written about this
in mass many times but there is this
kind of
pervasive idea that muscle protein
synthesis measured acutely is highly
predictive of hypertrophy over time and
that couldn't be further from the truth
acute muscle protein synthesis
measurements uh time and time again do a
fairly poor job of predicting
longitudinal hypertrophy uh you can make
them better so you know if you're
looking at
muscle protein synthesis
in well-trained lifters who are doing a
bout of exercise that they're relatively
accustomed to
and you're measuring muscle protein
synthesis for an extended period of time
that might be kind of predictive of
hypertrophy over time but certainly not
perfectly predictive you cannot treat
those measurements as if they're
synonymous with hypertrophy but if
you're looking at short
measurements like we're talking like six
hours or shorter looking at muscle
protein synthesis
that's not going to tell you much about
longitudinal hypertrophy over time
especially if you're looking at
measurements done in untrained people or
measurements in people doing a very
unaccustomed bout of exercise because
that acute muscle protein synthesis
response is
largely related to just repairing and
remodeling existing proteins that are
already there so if you have a really
damaging bout of unaccustomed exercise
in untrained people who are not used to
that type of muscle damage uh the muscle
protein synthesis response really is not
directly related to hypertrophy and is
not going to be very predictive of
hypertrophy over time so whenever we
actually have longitudinal evidence
looking at hypertrophy we should
prioritize that
rather than focusing exclusively on
short-term studies looking at muscle
protein synthesis
now part two of the question was is
there any difference over time comparing
two meals a day versus eating every
three three to four hours
and that's something we've talked about
on the show there i think there's pretty
good evidence that three large protein
feedings throughout the day is more
effective than two for promoting
hypertrophy but when you increase from
three to four or five or six there
doesn't seem to be much of a benefit
there so
one meal a day is getting kind of
popular
that's a viable way to eat i don't think
it's optimal for hypertrophy
time restricted feeding very popular i
personally wouldn't recommend a feeding
window any shorter than eight hours
because i do think it's valuable to get
at least three protein feedings with at
least a couple hours between them over a
span of time that's eight hours or
longer
um all right did you have the last one
you wanted to do i do yeah so uh
pleasant merit pawn on reddit uh says
slash asks uh conventional wisdom is
that you need to balance push and pull
exercises for shoulder health for
example you need to do rows and pull ups
to offset bench and overhead press is
there any research on this topic and
what do you guys think of this idea if
someone wanted to do 20 sets a week of
pressing do they need to do 20 cents a
week of pulling to lower their injury
risk
so um
just to start with
there is not
or at least i was unable to find good
research looking at this um
so i i spent a bit of time like you know
i didn't do a fully systematic lit
search as if i were trying to do a
systematic review on the topic but i ran
half a dozen pubmed queries looked
through the first several pages of
results to see if i could find human
evidence looking at one the ratio of
upper body pushing to pulling exercises
and and that
in the relation of that to shoulder
health or injury risk
and when that didn't turn up anything i
also just looked at uh upper body
pushing to pulling strength ratios and
whether research has found that to be
predictive of shoulder health or injury
risk and i came up dry both places um
and specifically on the latter batch of
research just looking at upper body
pushing to pulling strength ratios um
the the most recent study on that i
found from 2020 um which which i think
gives a good indication of where that
literature is uh in the introduction it
basically said like uh it has been
proposed that
if you have uh excessive pushing
strength relative to pulling strength
that might be
uh
a risk factor for shoulder injury but
then the the thing cited for that
sentence
didn't link to human evidence showing
that to be true it's basically just like
um like expert sources have said that if
you do see this then maybe that's
predictive of injury risk um but no like
without any actual data cited to
substantiate that claim
so that's basically the state of the
literature some people say like oh yeah
this might increase your injury risk but
then you say where's the data and uh as
far as i can tell it's not there and if
it does exist i
was unable to find it um so yeah
i i think that if you're very
comfortable with the null hypothesis
um
you you would say that like oh yeah this
doesn't seem to be predictive of injury
risk upper body pushing to pulling
strength ratios um how much pushing and
how many pushing and pulling movements
you do how many sets you do
um there's not good evidence that that
is predictive of injury risk for the
shoulder
so
however you know the
classic classic nugget absence of
evidence is not necessarily evidence of
absence
as far as i can tell there's no research
proving that that doesn't matter it's
just that there's not good human
research on it in the first place
um
so like i think that
um
so i think one of the reasons that the
idea got so popular that you need to do
a certain amount of pulling to offset
the pushing you do
um i think that that came from
the
vladimir janda idea of the upper cross
syndrome
which as i understand it has been pretty
thoroughly debunked at this point
however
what i'll also say is i think that
i think that idea was popularized not in
totality but at least in part by eric
cressey back in the day writing for t
nation
and i
uh
i i tend to think that eric is a good
source of information for various things
and specifically he mostly trains
baseball players
and what he said is that like hey when
these baseball guys come in and we have
them do more rows and more pull-ups they
seem to have fewer shoulder issues in
the subsequent baseball season um
and i have no reason to doubt him on
that but what i will also say
is that
something
the demands on your shoulders playing
baseball are way greater than the
demands on your shoulder when you're
just lifting weights so it might
simultaneously be true
that doing more pulling exercises is
good for
making the shoulders of baseball players
a bit more robust but that doesn't
necessarily mean that that will have a
huge impact on injury risk in the gym
because those are those are two very
different pursuits
um the other thing i'll say
is that they actually have two more
things to say one of them is that uh
boris shaco as i understand it pretty
good powerlifting coach um and you know
as one could use the argument from
authority saying well eric kressy says
this is a good thing to do you could
also use the argument from authority to
say like well you can look at shaco's
programs he doesn't have his guys do a
ton of rowing
and best i can tell his lifters haven't
traditionally had a catastrophic uh rate
of shoulder issues in spite of doing a
ton of benching and very very minimal
rowing so
uh you know you could you could use that
kind of counterpoint
as long as we're in the realm of
arguments from authority the other thing
i'll say is i also think
the
uh the idea that you need to do
a certain amount of pulling for each set
of pushing you do and that the ratio of
upper body pushing to pulling strength
is super important i i think part of
that may come just kind of from
reasoning from analogy
so
you go back
not not even all that long ago maybe
like 20 years ago or so um
there was a lot of research looking at
quad to hamstring strength ratios uh and
there were some suggestions that if you
had way stronger quads relative to your
hamstrings that might predispose you for
risk of acl tears and hamstring strains
i haven't checked in on that research in
a long time i don't know if that's still
the current
consensus view within within the field
uh but but that was something that a lot
of people were concerned about and there
was some preliminary research suggesting
that that may be the case that if your
quads are way too strong and or your
hamstrings are way too weak you might
strain your hamstrings more frequently
might tear your acls more frequently and
so i wonder if some of the concerns
around shoulder health were just kind of
reasoning from analogy based on that
research where if strength ratios across
the knee seem to matter
to some degree for injury risk maybe
that's a generalizably true phenomenon
that you can generalize to other joints
um
and so
you know that that may be one of the
things
uh motivating the reasoning behind being
concerned about this uh
but
as far as i'm aware
there's like i said to start with as far
as i'm aware there's not good human
evidence
validating that those
that you need to have those concerns and
also i'll note that the
sorts of injuries that you might see at
the shoulder tend to be quite a bit
different than than what you'd be
looking at with quadricep to hamstring
strength ratios like the the direct
analogy for a hamstring strain would be
a bicep strain for example um you know
not just kind of
general shoulder algaes and the analogy
for an acl strain would be
some sort of uh
strain or tear of the ligaments of the
elbow like those would be the the direct
analogies you you could draw from that
um
and before a physical therapist gets
angry and corrects us uh we're talking
about spraining ligaments not straining
them yes correct uh
but yeah so i i mean like the the sorts
of
injuries that you would directly
analogize from the quadriceps to
hamstring strength ratio stuff aren't
even the types of injuries that people
are concerned about uh when you talk
about shoulder injuries that you might
get from lifting or other sports so i
don't know that the analogy really holds
up and ultimately
reasoning from analogy is a very weak
form of evidence uh ideally you would
have direct human research on the thing
you're interested in
so yeah i mean my my general take on it
is that
for most people who are lifting
certainly doesn't hurt to do more
pulling um
you know a little bit of extra bicep
work you're gripping onto the implement
might grow your forearms a little bit
having a jacked back huge lats huge
traps it's a very cool physique and i'm
not aware of any lifting related pursuit
where that would be a hindrance to you
um
so yeah i mean i i think that if you
are concerned that you need to do a
certain amount of pulling per set of
pushing you do
i i don't think i don't think that's
going to hurt you at all
i think that's a
you know if even if it does turn out to
be an incorrect idea
the direct applications you would draw
from that idea i don't think are
particularly deleterious so if that does
turn out to be misinformation it's not
harmful misinformation so i don't care
that much
but as best i can tell
there's not
good reliable human data to suggest that
you need to do
a set of pulling per set of pushing in
order to preserve shoulder health
good stuff uh time got away from me a
little bit during this episode uh maybe
it was just too much reminiscing on my
my old days reading all jim stephanie's
articles and muscle and fitness
uh
so i i know that the cliffhanger ending
uh is not a fan favorite but i did have
a nice little answer presented someone
was asking about whether or not protein
requirements scale to
total body mass or fat free mass that's
a common question and i will answer that
but we simply do not have time for this
episode so in a
in the near future i'll be talking a
little bit about whether or not protein
requirements should be just kind of
stable
you know for all people or if we need to
be scaling those to body weight or or
fat free mass and it's a really
interesting question because there's
surprisingly not that much evidence
looking at it directly um you know
there's
one paper that i can think of mcnaughton
in in 2016 that said hey we're going to
kind of do a median split and see if the
people with a lot of fat free mass need
more protein than the people with less
fat free mass to
maximize muscle protein synthesis
but for a lot of reasons i really don't
think that that particular study is
sufficient to really get at the root of
the question there
but we'll get into that in a future
episode tonight for now i'm going to
play us out with a humble travel
recommendation for a place that i've
never been to
so i started watching uh the 72 cutest
animals on netflix uh it's a really
gripping show a lot of drama my
girlfriend and i were watching it and
our jaws hit the floor a couple times
with some of their decisions it's it's
really controversial
but uh if you're looking for something
that's lovely to watch and not gonna
require a lot of thinking or uh you know
not gonna induce bad vibes 72 cutest
animals is as uh as nice as it sounds
but
in the course of watching that show i
learned about a place called rotnest
island in australia this is a
very small island it's only 19 square
kilometers which is about 7.3 square
miles off the coast of western australia
you might be wondering why i'm
recommending it and why i would bring it
up on this show well
the quaka is the only animal
or the only mammal i should say that is
native to rottnest island
and they can be found almost everywhere
on the island
this island supports the largest known
quaka population
and in this small island 7.3 square
miles there are about ten thousand to
twelve thousand of these little guys
running around this was a
uh a huge fan favorite of the show when
greg mentioned cuakas and in the
stronger by science group people were
sharing all their favorite pictures of
these cute little animals
and there are no bad pictures no they
they all look like the cutest little
fuzzy smiling
uh little buddy with very chubby cheeks
that is what they all look like a very
very cute animal shockingly
not ranked well in the show
that's one kind of content warning if
you're defensive about quokkas maybe you
don't want to watch that show because
they're not number one and they are not
close that is unconscionable i'm only
two episodes in so it's it they'll only
go down from here
um but an interesting thing related to
the show um
i'm thinking that our our dutch
listeners all three of them out there
are probably not going to want to visit
uh rot nest island i think the
um the cuteness of the koaka just does
not seem to be recognized in the
netherlands and the reason i bring that
up on the show
they mentioned that
dutch sailors uh landed there in several
occasions um this is kind of from the
show kind of from from wikipedia
but around the 17th century there are a
lot of dutch sailors around there and
they actually gave the island its name
uh but it's basically a translated
version of rats nest island uh they saw
all of these adorable cute little
quadcas with their smiles and their
chubby cheeks and they said look at this
giant nest of rats that is what we shall
call the island i'm so mad yeah so
um that's [ __ ] in a way though it's
kind of nice because uh
our show
didn't get the best reviews coming out
of the netherlands when we first
released it that was the impetus for the
ongoing feud that is really
uh
as contentious as ever it's never really
cooled off but you know
if you negatively review a quokka then
i'd say sure negatively review my show
you know like that that's kind of a nice
thing we have in common with cuakas i
think
so um
i highly recommend going to this island
i will go there someday and and hang out
with the quokkas but uh
if you're dutch and you think cuakas
look like rats it might not be the place
for you because that's about 12 000 rats
and they are everywhere according to the
show
all right so i think that does it for
this episode of the podcast as always
thank you for listening we will be back
in a week with another episode
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you